[Applause]
and finally new rule it's depressing
enough having just had a birthday in
being 66 please don't ask me to start
doing grown-up things like run for
president
a few weeks ago fox news's dana perino a
former bush press secretary suggested
that the democrats
should recruit me to run for president
which is kind of special because it
means that in the space of 20 years
bush press secretaries have gone from
telling me i need to watch what i say
they need to to watch what they say
watch what they do and this is not
a time for remarks like that there never
is
they've gone from that to wondering if i
should run for president
it'll be interesting to see if bill
maher is recruited to run for
the presidency
now some people think this means i've
changed i assure you i have not
i am still the same unmarried childless
pot-smoking libertine i always was
i have many flaws but you can't accuse
me of maturing
[Applause]
let's get this straight it's not me
who's changed it's the left
who is now made up of a small contingent
who've gone mental and a large
contingent who refused to call them out
for it but i will that's why i'm a hero
at fox these days
which shows just how much liberals have
their head up their ass because if they
really thought about it they would have
made me a hero on their media
but
but that can't happen in this ridiculous
new era of mind-numbing partisanship
where if i keep it real about the
nonsense in the democratic party it
makes me an instant hero to republicans
the same thing happened in reverse to
darth vader's daughter liz cheney
who is now a hero to liberals simply
because she recognizes biden did not
steal the last election what a sad
commentary on our politics where simply
acknowledging reality is now seen as a
profile in courage
people sometimes say to me
you know you didn't you didn't used to
make fun of the left as much
yeah because they didn't give me so much
to work with
the oath of office
i took was to comedy
and if you do goofy [ __ ] wherever you
are in the spectrum i'm going to make
fun of you because that's where the gold
is and the fact that they are laughing
at it should tell you something it rings
true
when
normal people read that san francisco
has basically legalized shoplifting
they think democrats have gone nuts
they think you know that ted cruz cruz
guy
seems like a real stiff
but at least he believes in the concept
of shopping with money
it's not
it's not my fault that the party of fdr
and jfk is turning into the party of lol
and wtf
[Applause]
members of congress
tweeting things like cancel rent
cancel mortgage and no more policing or
incarceration
declaring that capitalism is slavery
canceling lincoln and dr seuss teaching
children their oppressors and math is
racist making mr potato head
gender-neutral
and now an emoji for pregnant men
real i'm not making it up
california just passed a law requiring
large retailers to have a non-gendered
toy section a non-gendered toy section
isn't ken enough
[Applause]
we need a law for that you have to
inject yourselves into everything from
where you can throw a frisbee to who can
braid hair
this is why so many people by the way
were triggered by covid policies they
were already sick of rules
regulation
should be a good issue for democrats
it's certainly one they're associated
with and i think the average voter would
agree that banks and chemical plants and
drug companies
need watching
telling a company
you can't dump the waste from your hog
farm straight into the water supply
we're mostly all for that
but democrats have become a parody of
themselves just making rules to make
rules because it makes you feel like
you're a better person
making sure that everything bad never
happens again
which you can never fully do it just
makes everyone else's life a drag
the biden infrastructure bill has a
provision that requires all new cars to
install an alert system that goes off
when you leave a baby in the back seat
which is something done only by
crackheads
and people who sadly yes do it on
purpose and after every one of us winds
up bearing the cost for cars to install
this alarm you know who's going to
ignore it crackheads and people who do
it on purpose
a sensor light is not going to fix this
problem and democrats no longer possess
the common sense to understand that not
every problem in the world can be fixed
with the regulation
but don't tell that to the advocacy
groups who also want every future car in
america to only start when the driver
blows into a breathalyzer oh great my
other car is a karen
[Applause]
well
you know it's also not safe to drive
when you're crying
to do should we make a car that follows
your texts and stops the engine when
you're dumped
[Applause]
racism is bad how about a car that won't
start unless you play a message about
tolerance from george takei
[Applause]
regular viewers of this program may
recall my long battle to get solar power
hooked up at my house
it involved this shed which had to be
built to house this solar battery
yes that battery needed a house to live
in
and not just any house one that had to
follow the specifications of this chart
that's a real chart of the steps we had
to go through to get this thing turned
on
democrats have to stop thinking that
what the voters dream about is to be
hassled
if you buy a shed at costco it comes
with this warning
warning this product can expose you to
wood dust
wood dust
no kidding which is known to the state
of california to cause cancer that's
right california thinks you're going to
snort your shed
[Applause]
i don't want to blow pinocchio i just
want to put the lawnmower away
you